OK, let's get into audience questions for
the week as we see more vaccines roll out,
surpassing one point one and even one point two
million vaccines per day over the last few days,
which is fantastic to see, although there's much
more acceleration that still needs to be done.
I'm getting more and more questions like how
long will mask wearing continue? The answer
to this question is so complicated because first
of all, many people never started wearing masks.
There are people who still just aren't wearing
masks. Mask enforcement varies drastically in
different states within the U.S. and in different
countries. But I think the best way to get into
this topic is to understand two things. Number
one, how long mask wearing continues will in great
part depend on how well different countries,
regions or states are handling the virus.
The mask wearing will be necessitated
by the virus continuing to spread and
kill people. So the places that best and most
quickly deal with the virus will most quickly
be able to get away from mask wearing. Now,
that being said, the more and to be clear, none
of this I am I don't pretend to be an expert on
this. I have just been gathering the opinions of
experts on masks, wearing the cultural and medical
ends of the pandemic are likely not to coincide.
The medical end would be herd immunity has
been reached and they are not of this virus
has come down to some very low level. And that is
likely to happen after the numbers are low enough
that in particular, people who are not at huge
risk, who have been vaccinated are ready to say,
I am going back to life sort of as normal. The
other thing that's important now, when that will
be, if vaccination continues, I think I'm not
saying this is right, but you are going to see
dramatically decreased mask usage probably by
summer in a lot of areas for folks who are at
risk and who are going to remain more careful
for a longer period of time or indefinitely.
The masking in large, crowded areas may not stop
for years. And that's part of what we were talking
about last week with Nicholas Christakis, about
there's a psychological and societal impact here
where during flu season there was a risk to going
out without a mask for older folks and folks with
compromised immune systems. It was always there,
but it was not talked about in the terms it's
talked about. Now, with coronavirus, even after
coronavirus is dealt with, you may have folks
in those categories who simply during flu season
are wearing a mask anyway because they recognize
that the level of risk that was always there
is no longer comfortable without a mask. That
remains to be seen. I do think it's important to
mention that mask wearing. First of all, globally,
the United States is somewhat unique in that
there has been such a large political movement
that considers wearing a piece of cloth over
your face when around other people some kind
of massive imposition on liberty and freedom.
The Trump administration definitely resisted
mask wearing in order to downplay the pandemic.
It was a pretty unnatural argument to sustain when
you saw how other countries were handling it and
many other countries were sort of confused. Why
why are there so many Americans who think
just putting a piece of cloth over your
face is something you should resist? It
just reduces the chance of spread. We don't
know exactly by how much we can debate and
study, exactly how much it reduces it. But
if it reduces it at all, then it seems like
a good idea. It was not the political issue
that it became in the United States elsewhere. But
regardless, it's still quite popular in the United
States. Look at early numbers, early polling
about Joe Biden's actions on coronavirus. About
80 percent of the country agrees with Joe Biden's
mask mandate, which, remember, it's only a mandate
for federal buildings and federal workers. And on
interstate transportation like trains and planes
within states and at normal places of employment
and out in downtowns, it's still up to governors
to enact and enforce. And it's sort of more of
a mask plea than it is a mask mandate. But it
still has 80 percent support. So I think that we
are going to see widespread mask usage continue,
certainly through the first half of twenty twenty
one, whether it should or not. If vaccination
continues and cases go down and deaths go down,
you will see reduced masking, particularly in
warmer areas by the summer. I think there's almost
no doubt that you are going to see it. I'm not
advocating for it. I'm just saying that's likely
to be the case. And of course, we are going to see
that the. Economy is very closely paid
attention to if you see more in-person
things happening, although at first it will
likely all be as long as people are wearing masks.
I think that relatively quickly you will
see people drop the masks for better or
worse. I'm not advocating for it, but that's
sort of the trajectory that I'm anticipating.